die kündigung also also blockbusters
spitzname ist knolle wieder von bob der
baumeister
hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video heute euch wieder christian
dabei und werden wir schon mal vor zwei
drei monaten dinge die mädchen an jungs
nicht verstehen special edition gemacht
das heißt ihr habt uns auf install
infrage gestellt oder halt sachen gesagt
die ihr halt ein jungs nicht versteht
und die wollen wir heute wieder
beantworten
wir haben uns ein paar rausgesucht wird
euch ganz viel spaß und weil solche
fällt das tor nach oben und wurde nicht
vergessen und like und kommentierten das
war zu viel aber es geht los
warum finden jungs natürliche medien
immer schöner sind aber trotzdem mit
seiner überschminken zusammen spielen
frage ich finde das stimmt nicht
unbedingt also klar man findet ich also
ich persönlich finde wenn sich mädchen
gar nicht schmeckt dann also bisher
ungepflegt oder so und wenn sie sich ein
bisschen schminke reicht das volk also
aber nur ein bisschen nicht so ein stück
und an einer so langen und klebte ein
bisschen natürlich seid das mädchen
schon rüber kommt aber warum jetzt
manche leute mit so richtig krass
geschminkten zusammen sind kann ich
nicht beantworten ich auch nicht
erkannte das eben so wir machen weiter
mit der zweiten statement frage anfrage
keine ahnung wieso antwortet ihr nie
nicht immer also warum ignoriert er ein
manchmal obwohl man die was gemacht hat
also da würde ich dir sagen es gibt das
ist dann einfach der grund dass der
junge kein interesse an hat oder aber
danach ausgesehen war nicht antworten
ich antworte auch manchmal auch wenn der
nie antwortet oder halt sagen immer nie
etwas zu sagen wenn er nicht antwortet
dann sagt man sachen vom er dann hat man
meistens verkackt eben wie sehr stehen
die jungs eigentlich ballerspiele ja
wiese steht nicht auf meiner spieler
alex warum ich stehe nicht auf meiner
spiele ich spiele gar nichts mehr außer
fifa und ballerspiele ich habe das
früher mal gezockt aber mich spricht das
überhaupt nicht mehr an
warum
beteiligungen du läufst irgendwo lang
und knapp die verweise ich hab dich lieb
ich hab ne kamera
das hatte ich aber nie doch normal
bleibst mein account ich gottes meiner
glaube nicht wissen warum jungs liegen
shoppen gehen jedenfalls die meisten man
kann ja auch in die läden von den jungen
gibt das liegt ganz einfach daran immer
wenn ich irgendeinen scheiß geschäft
rein gehen wo sie erst zehn kilometer
die treppen hoch waren damit überhaupt
in der männerabteilung listet das ist
wichtig und deswegen also ich gehe schon
mit jungs so ist okay was einkaufen geht
5 t shirts oder wenn manche braucht aber
mit einer freundin gehe ich auch nicht
so gerne einkaufen weil ich so lange
dauert und dann läuft man dahin und
daher nur dahin und dahin und toni füße
sie erhitzt jahrhundert war von mädchen
haben einfach in die mehr motivation als
richtig will sich vor allem immer wenn
man sport machen oder so dann joggen und
dann können sie sagen nach zehn minute
tut wie und wenn ihr also schon alles
gute warum wissen jungs immer so schnell
was sie anziehen sollen ich gehe halt
vom ein kleiderschrank nehmen irgendwann
raus egal ob es jetzt besser aussieht
als gestern oder schlimmer und ziehen
deshalb nicht mein mädchen ich weiß
nicht was bei euch anders läuft aber
kontrollierbar system vom bahnhof nach
genau evaluiert marktbreit kontrast an
wild cherry haar muss laut passauer
farbe oder sowas
dieses wie ist es immer kalt crash oder
so wenn du so und so
woran ich mich hier so ach ja so leute
das war's mit dem video falls ihr
gefallen hat dass auf jeden fall doch
nach oben da hier kommt ihr zu seinem
instagram auf jeden fall abschicken und
folgen hier kommt ihr zu meinen und
nicht vergessen wir haben bald 50.000
abonnenten richtigkeit und die auf der
linken seite geht's weiter mit meinem
besten über das war mit meinem bruder
und hier auf der also nicht mit ihm
sondern mit meinem richtigen und hier
auf der anderen seite mit dem letzten
teil 1 der ja genau 21 check auf jeden
fall ab wir sind uns nächstes mal wieder
haut rein leute okay gut